[Música]
no lugar certo a oi lançou ricardo e
hoje vou falar sobre o rio pinheiros
o motivo de eu falar que o rio é porque
eu sou sócio do pinheiros e também
porque ele era um problemão o germania
germânico mas que depois da segunda
guerra mundial teve que trocar seu nome
que escolheu o esporte clube pinheiros
na homenagem ao rio passar ali que era
utilizado para lazer pelos seus sócios
aqui mostra o rio pinheiros hoje em azul
como era antigamente mas porque o rio
pinheiros e assim hoje não começou na
década de 20 são paulo que ele é muito
rápido e com ela as fábricas e eles
precisavam de mais energia elétrica
então uma empresa do canadá chamada
light conseguiu o direito de vender
energia elétrica para a cidade
o estudante de geografia do lugar eles
construir uma hidrelétrica em cubatão
aproveitando os 700 metros de queda
d'água da serra do mar para abastecer a
usina eles construir um reservatório no
alto da serra do mar chamado rio grande
bom agora quando a gente vai pra praia
você já sabe o que são aqueles tubos
enormes que ficam na cena bom e dá um
problema de energia elétrica resolvida
né
sakineh porque no inverno quase não
chove eo nível do reservatório fica
muito baixo e faltava água para
abastecer a usina então único engenheiro
da life chamado chamado aos ambientes
falou vamos usar o rio pinheiros
então agora vai dar tudo certo sem
complicações ainda que o curso do rio
pinheiros não ia para a serra do mar e é
para interior jack inverter o curso do
rio agora vai dar certo também porque o
pinheiros era muito torto ele não
conseguia fazer nada assim
então como
o projeto serra que demorou mais de 20
anos e que quando terminado tinham rio
pinheiros que edificado e duas usinas
elevatórias de traição e de pereira que
também serve como um tipo de barragem
para represar o rio grande que estão em
ambientes na homenagem o engenheiro que
retificou o rio pinheiros
mas com o rio pinheiros certificado não
tinha mais enchente em suas margens e o
terreno começou a ficar muito valorizado
e ocupação acabou sendo rápida e sem
investimento então esgoto acaba vendo
sem tratamento primeiros
ele começou a ficar bonito
mesmo hoje com a sabesp deixando
bastante para a coleta e tratamento de
esgoto industrial ainda 400 mil famílias
famílias jogam seus gostos em tratamento
pro rio pinheiros e por causa disso de
90 ele não é mais utilizado e a
hidrelétrica só funciona com 25 por
cento da sua capacidade como todos
sabemos hoje o rio pinheiros é um lugar
muito poluída e causou vários problemas
como mau feira
no verão o aparecimento dessas algas que
aumentam a quantidade de mosquitos que
transmitem doenças como dengue e zica e
o contato com suas águas também
transmitem outras doenças como a
hepatite cólera infecções
mas quais benefício nós teríamos
chuveiros fosse limpo bom
alguns deles seriam a hidrelétrica
voltaria a funcionar com 100% da sua
capacidade novamente a gente poderia
nadar e brincar no rio condições que eu
tenho por ele
a gente poderia fazer transporte de
pessoas e de carga pelo rio é turismo e
também porque não pescar no rio né ele
teria vida de novo mas o que nós podemos
fazer pelo rio pinheiros hoje nós não
devemos jogar lixo na rua no chão que
vai pra boca de lobo e depois acaba indo
pro rio pinheiros e o mais importante é
devagar mas vai
ano que vem tem as eleições nós devemos
votar em candidatos que se comprometam
com o pinheiros trabalhando para a
urbanização das construções irregulares
ea finalização de coleta coleta e
tratamento de esgoto para toda a grande
são paulo
agora vou mostrar um vídeo que mostra
alguns sonhos que eu tenho do rio 2010
eo livro comunidade
essa foi a apresentação também tenham
gostado obrigado